Hello, this is Dr. Cabin-Cutters and welcome to module five call this program at you right, but really
We're gonna talk about other technologies a little bit as well. We have
We'll actually have some other videos not just on the right, but on other technologies
On this site soon as well, so if you can't find it make sure you come back and we'll get those up as soon as possible
but
Always the practice of medicine is trying to use more and more technology as technology becomes available
We want to use it, but would you search cancer technologies out there?
You're gonna hear about different robotic surgeries. You're gonna hear about bone marrow transplant targeted therapy immunotherapy
You know, these are all medical technologies and they can be very good
And they can be very hard on your body as well
That's what we're talking about. It's an alternative perspective. We're not talking about using these kind of things on this slide
We're talking about using specific therapies
So I speak about a lot of those different therapies in my book on our website. We speak about a lot of those different therapies
Hyperthermia is a great therapy to help stimulate
Bioflow and liver detoxification can help decrease pain
It can help specifically kill cancers that are near the surface like certain breast cancers and even skin cancer
So hyperthermia is raising the temperature of the tissue to a point where it's safe for healthy normal cells, but for cancer cells that are
You could say less more fragile
Increasing the temperature of that cancer cell can literally cause cell lysis. That's a type of pathological death that we want to take place in a cancer cell
So hyperthermia is one of those technologies
Pemf pulsed electromagnetic field therapy is another therapy. That isn't really a cancer killing therapy
But it can help with other side effects from cancer therapies or a cancer itself with pain or
Just lack of energy what a Pemf unit does is adds a charge of electricity to your body in a pulsed fashion
Like I'm talking like this because it's giving you this boom boom boom electrical charge
Which all your cell membranes have an electrical charge so by adding this post-electromagnetic field
Charged to your cells. It can really help boost fatigue levels, energy levels, constricted, healthy cells
Can strengthen your immune system and indirectly then be good to help kill cancer cells
But I wouldn't say it's a cancer killing therapy
But if you have access to a Pemf cancer patients do really well
It adds to your whole protocol in body health
So Pemf therapy is a great addition. Plus it's we like to use it with patients that may have metastasis. It's a bone
And have paid because of that because probably the number one use of Pemf worldwide is really for pain
For people with chronic pain or a de-injury or back injury Pemf really shines for that
So certainly with metastasis or pain for your cancer for any reason
Pemf can be very beneficial
Of course if you've watched any of my information
The rife machine is really big in my book. That's how I got started
Taking care of cancer patients is because of this love for this rife machine that
God put in my heart way back in the 1980s when I was in school
When it seems like a long time ago now. I'm an old man, but the rife machine was
It's just a great tool. That's how I started taking care of patients with the cancer diagnosis
God really instilled in my heart this love of this rife machine
I just had this just desire you know says in the book of Hosea that he will put his desires in your heart
He will give you the desires of your heart and I read that as God will put his desires in your heart
He certainly put that desire about rife technology in my heart
First time I saw anything about Royal Raymond rife in his work. I was intrigued and
Before I purchased my first machine
I had investigated the types of rife machines that were out there in the 90s because that's what I was looking at them
I had said I had called the company sent had them sent some
Information this is before really the internet and they I had some a pamphlet of the rife machine that I was going to buy
Taped up to my desk on the wall in front of my desk at my clinic
And it wasn't until the late 90s when a patient came in and said she had breast cancer in both breasts and
They gave her three months to live if she didn't do chemo
She wasn't gonna do chemo
That was my aha moment my Holy Spirit moment to buy a rife machine
Purchased a rife machine she came in daily and used it. That's when we did it in our office and she lived another 13 years. So
I don't take credit for that. I don't even give her the rife machine credit for that. Obviously God is our healer
He's the one who kept that person alive and
Lived you know years beyond what was expected
But I do give some credit to where God leads us and the rife machine is what he led me to that is a big part of my purpose
Is to help people with frequency. So what is the rife machine the rife machine is?
Using technology to our benefit. It is a hidden gem
It was really
Invented initially by royal rabid rife heads the name of it
But there's a lot of different rife quote-un-me quote machines out there that I wouldn't call rife machines
Because to me if it's truly a rife machine it has to use light
Frequency so if you're holding on to some little
Panels or you're putting little stickers on your body or you're listening to an audio through headphones or something
It is frequency therapy and it is frequency healing and I'm not discounting the benefits to that
But if you really want to help kill cancer cells
I think by opinion you need to use light frequencies
So royal rabid rife is the inventor he was a microscope manufacturer and you could read all about him on our website
We'll put some links to different things about him on this
site as well
But he is the one who this was in the burgeoning of
Quantum physics and quantum mechanics when the understanding went beyond
Newtonian physics to an understanding that everything down to its smallest particle is simply energy that's vibrating at a
specific frequency and a fairly unique frequency to that thing
So that's what makes that thing up and that's really in the
Understanding of quantum physics is what royal rabid rife came up with if we could hit cancer frequency
Cancer cells at their own frequency. Could we cause them to implode?
Could we cause lysis a
Pathological death of that cancer cell that was his philosophy
He didn't have any way to prove that
Though he could do it in a petri dish
Well, not everything works in the body the way it works at a petri dish
But he did have success with patients and then the 1950s rolled around and that's when the
AMA was coming in confiscating any
Practitioner that was not using pharmacology
That's when all the cancer clinics in Mexico were birthed because these people were run out of the country
Hoxy and Gerson well rife just gave up the ghost because they confiscated his machines and
He ended up dying in alcoholic very sad situation
But his technology wasn't totally lost the government used it during the Cold War to try to actually to try to use it
To create germ so if we found the frequency for anthrax could we
Hit somebody run it on a rife machine hit somebody with the frequency of anthrax and cause anthrax
Well the problem with that is it doesn't cause disease if that person had anthrax
It would help their body kill anthrax
It doesn't cause anthrax so it was scrapped into the freedom of information act
All this money spent on mapping out the quantum physics frequency for
Thousands of diseases was made available to practitioners like me
So and then you add that to the decades of work of different practitioners
Trying to figure out the frequencies of different cancers and what will work best for different cancers
We have come up with a lot of different frequencies for a most every cancer there is and
That's the use of rife today using these frequencies to our advantage. Yes, his work was suppressed knowledge
And it really went into the dark ages in the 50s in the 60s
But when the 70s rolled around and people started reading about some of his stuff
practitioners like me and a lot of people smarter than me started to create some different machines that had an
Advantage and could help people with cancer the first machine I bought in the 90s was probably
About a 50th time is powerful as the machines we use today
So as this knowledge advances and as technology advances
We're able to create better machines that are going to have a better effect on the body
So we use this machine right here a true rife in the office
We also use a GP4000, but this is the one that we use that we send home with patients
And this is the one that I really sell because of a couple factors
So what I analyze a type of rife machine and what I want to use for myself or my patients
And look at a few different factors
Number one isn't powerful enough to produce energy out of that bulb that is going to penetrate by body to affect the
Cancer that's deep in my body
So there's a lot of rife machines on the market or machines that call themselves rife machines that
Do not do that. So they might have some effect on
Superficial things, but they're not powerful enough to penetrate your body. So well to be what good is that?
Secondly, does it use light frequency? I already talked about that if you're not using light frequency for cancer
I think you're missing the boat completely
So it does have to have a Tesla tube a gas valve tube that do the light frequency to carry that wave through your body
And then thirdly, is it programmable? So I mean if there's just some programmed
Things with the machine they may be good. They may be bad, but they're not necessarily going to be specific to me
So if it's not programmable for me, I don't want to use it because I want to get very specific to the frequencies that I want to run
So the gb4000 or the true rife are really the two that are left with that
And then lastly, is it really easy to use and is it going to last a long time?
so
To me, that's where the true rife shines. I have no investment in this company
And I probably shouldn't even mention their name on here, but you can go to a rife and buy one of their machines
I have no problem with that. I think you should think everybody should have one my kids have one that don't have cancer
So my grandkids could use it if they come down with a cold or anything like that
These this is where the rife machine shines. It shines on killing biotoxins
It shines on helping your body kill cancer cells. Kivi killing living things. That's where the rife shines as a tool
You want to use any tool correctly?
You don't use a hammer to pound in a screw. You don't use a screwdriver to pound in a nail
So you you use tools as they're created
So this is where the rife shines we put on there. There's over 2,500 different programs and then we get specific for that person's type of cancer and I've written
Doing this for 20 some years. I've written a program for just about every possible cancer. There is
My cancer was extremely rare. There was zero known frequencies for my cancer
And I actually struggled and you if you read on our website
About my personal experience. I really didn't think I was gonna make it three years ago. I was pretty positive
I wasn't and there was some dark days there
But it wasn't until I figured out the frequency that worked for me that it really changed the quarter it turned the quarter for me and where I
Why am speaking to you today?
So I give rife a lot of credit. I'm very thankful for what this man did in his work
I'm thankful for how God used him even though he wasn't a believer
God still uses things to his and for his glory
That's my belief. So using the right frequencies is key. The true I comes with about
2500 other programs that I said and then we specifically create a program for this specific cancer and that person and
You can purchase one of our programs
It wouldn't be specific to a cheek swab test
But it will be specific to your type of cancer and that can be extremely beneficial
So it's all in the program. It it's all in the power of the machine
It's in the light frequency. It's in the ease of use of the machine
Of course, I'm really big pushing the rife machine
But you know, I don't need to make anything off it go buy it from true rife
I don't make anything for you doing that. So understand I'm not trying to be biased
But by opinion is biased just because of what I've experienced and
The way God has used me and how he's led me in my desires
I honestly don't think I'd be standing here talking you today if it wasn't for the rife machine. So
I am very biased about it, but it is
It is a blood has been a blessing in my life in my family's life as well and a lot of my patients
This is the machine. This is the bulb that we use. We use actually a crystallized bulb
Which I think helps separate the light and give you even a better benefit as the cancer tries to morph and try to take off
every way possibly it can
So we use the f-20 f-122 with all our patients and they sleep with this crystal hammer bulb. That's what it's called
It's encased in plastic
So if you drop it out of bed and you can't break the thing
But you snuggle with it all night long. I snuggle with my bulb all night long or it lays right next to me
and I use it every single night. So
um
It is a great tool. So consider different technology as it comes up
But be wise don't just talk to one the salesperson. I have tested just about every rife on the market
And this is what I use
There's some other good ones too
And I'm not knocking any other products out there, but I just want to use the best thing for me and for my patients
I mean, I feel like that's my responsibility
So I'm not going to recommend something that I don't like
What I don't think works, but if new technology comes out, I guess and remake this video. So um
Hope this is a blessing. Hope I don't sound salesy to you. I just want what's best for you
I and I want you to do the best thing and ultimately I want you to be praying about every decision you make
Certainly don't go by your right machine because I said it
Be praying about it be asking for that fruit of the spirit especially that peace
And that self-control that you need as you're walking by his his
Guidance so that you know that you know that you know you're doing the right thing
All right, I'll be praying for you and I come at your prayers for me and our clinic
Um until next module
Bye-bye